Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Trouble sleeping? It's something of a tradition, Guinan.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。失眠吗？这算是一种传统了，吉南。
Captain touring the ship before a battle. Hmm. Before a hopeless battle, if I remember the tradition correctly. Not necessarily. Nelson toured the HMS Victory before Trafalgar. Yes, but Nelson never returned from Trafalgar, did he? No, but the battle was won. That, Dominic, was Whoopi Goldberg as Guinan
舰长在战前巡视舰船。嗯。如果我没记错这个传统的话，是在一场无望的战斗之前。不一定。纳尔逊在特拉法加海战前就巡视了胜利号。是的，但纳尔逊没有从特拉法加回来，不是吗？不，但胜利赢了。多米尼克，刚才那是乌比·戈德堡饰吉南
and Patrick Stewart as Captain Jean-Luc Picard from Star Trek The Next Generation. If you had given me a thousand guesses, I would not have guessed that one of those people was whoopi goldberg it was so uh that is uh from the episode the best of both worlds which sees the um the enterprise facing its deadliest enemy yet the borg um and uh jean-luc picard is supposedly um french but is he he drinks he drinks earl grey tea uh he loves shakespeare and uh facing a hopeless battle here he conjures up nelson so good for him i think he's very english frenchman um anyway so that is my way of introducing today's episode, which I'm hoping, Dominic, will take us to the eve of the battle. So just like Jean-Luc Picard is waiting to take on the Borg, we will end up with Nelson waiting to take on the French and Spanish fleets off the Cape of Trafalgar.
以及帕特里克·斯图尔特饰让-吕克·皮卡尔舰长，出自《星际迷航：下一代》。如果你让我猜一千次，我也不会猜到其中一人是乌比·戈德堡，这太……嗯，那是出自那一集《最优选择》，剧中企业号面对着迄今为止最致命的敌人——博格人；嗯，让-吕克·皮卡尔据说是法国人，但他真的是吗？他喝伯爵茶，他热爱莎士比亚，嗯，在面对这场毫无胜算的战斗时，他召唤出了纳尔逊，所以他做得很好，我认为他是一个非常英国化的法国人。不管怎样，这就是我引入今天节目的方式，多米尼克，我希望这能带我们来到战役的前夕。所以，正如让-吕克·皮卡尔正等待着与博格人交战一样，我们最终也将看到纳尔逊在特拉法加角外等待着迎战法国和西班牙联合舰队。
Brilliant analogy, Tom. Brilliant. Thank you very much. Fantastic podcasting. Well, you love a popular culture reference i mean i know you because you think it's too earnest but um i do but um yeah fine i applaud your use of um popular culture use of star trek yeah exactly so last time we talked about the deep background of the battle of trafalgar the geopolitical position we talked about the institutional history of the Royal Navy, the way in which the Navy was the reflection of financial, political, economic forces that had been gathering strength in Britain, I suppose, since the 1650s or the 1690s or the 1740s,
绝妙的比喻，汤姆。绝妙。非常感谢。精彩的播客。好吧，你就是喜欢流行文化梗，我知道是因为你觉得它太严肃了，不过……我确实喜欢，好吧，很好，我为你对流行文化、对《星际迷航》的使用鼓掌，哈哈，完全正确。所以上一次我们谈到了特拉法加海战的深层背景、地缘政治地位，我们谈到了皇家海军的制度历史，海军在多大程度上反映了自1650年代、1690年代或1740年代以来
or you choose your date. 1580s. But now, yeah, Isaiah, you were wittering about Alfred the Great, I'm sure, at some point. But listen, we should now, Tom, enter the 19th century. Yes. You want to talk a little bit about the characters to you, and particularly Nelson. Do you want to start with Nelson? Well, I thought it would make sense to talk about who is fighting in the battle. So we've got, obviously, the admirals, the captains, the men on both sides.
或者你选个别的日期，1580年代——在英国汇聚力量的金融、政治和经济力量。但现在，呃，以赛亚，你肯定在某个时候喋喋不休地谈论过阿尔弗雷德大帝。不过听着，汤姆，我们现在应该进入19世纪了。是的。你想稍微谈谈其中的人物，特别是纳尔逊吗？你想从纳尔逊开始吗？好吧，我觉得讨论一下在这场战役中交战的都是些什么人是很有意义的。所以我们有，很显然，双方的舰队司令、舰长和士兵们。
And Trafalgar is really synonymous with Nelson because it's his strategy, it's his tactics that results in the victory. And of course, because he dies in the battle. We're on a patriotic streak at the moment, aren't we? We've celebrated British fashion in the Regency period. We did three episodes on Churchill and now we're doing Trafalgar. Where do you think Nelson stands in the pantheon of British heroes? Oh, he's obviously in the top rank, in the very top rank. I mean, he has his column. If you've got a column, if you're a column, you're a top hero, aren't you?
而特拉法加几乎就等同于纳尔逊，因为正是他的战略和战术带来了胜利。当然，也是因为他在战役中阵亡了。我们现在正处于一种爱国主义的热潮中，不是吗？我们庆祝了摄政时期的英国时尚，我们做了三集关于丘吉尔的节目，现在我们正在做特拉法加。你认为纳尔逊在英国英雄的万神殿中处于什么地位？哦，他显然在最高层，在绝对的最高层。我的意思是，他有他的纪念柱。如果你有一根纪念柱，如果你是一根纪念柱，你就是顶级英雄，对吧？
There has been, I think, a reasonably sort of fruitless attempt to cancel him. I mean, people don't try to cancel you unless you are somebody. But, I mean, a completely failed campaign, not even a campaign really, just to sort of cancel him, which never got anywhere. Nelson, I think to most ordinary Britons, I mean, when they had the Great Britons competition at the beginning of the 21st century, Nelson was in the top 10.
我认为曾有过某种毫无结果的试图取消他的尝试。我的意思是，除非你是个大人物，否则人们是不会试图取消你的。但是，我的意思是，这是一场彻底失败的运动，甚至算不上运动，只是一种试图取消他的尝试，最终毫无结果。我认为对于大多数普通英国人来说——我的意思是，当他们在21世纪初举办“最伟大的英国人”评选时，纳尔逊进入了前10名。
I think to most ordinary Britons, Nelson is one of the four or five people who is synonymous with britishness with british heroism so he's up there with the only people who rival him tom i would say in the public imagination i'm talking about people who are not interested in history are churchill i suppose elizabeth the first you know possibly alfred but maybe alfred but i mean nelson is more famous than alfred i would say yes i think so I suppose, Elizabeth I, you know. Possibly Alfred. Maybe Alfred. But I mean, Elston is more famous than Alfred, I would say. Yes, I think so.
我想对于大多数普通英国人来说，纳尔逊是与英国精神、与英国英雄主义紧密相连的四五个人之一。所以他位居前列，汤姆，我可以说，在公众想象中能与他匹敌的——我指的是那些对历史不感兴趣的人——只有丘吉尔，我想还有伊丽莎白一世，你知道的，可能还有阿尔弗雷德，但也许是阿尔弗雷德……不过我的意思是，纳尔逊比阿尔弗雷德更有名，我会这么说。是的，我想是的。我想，伊丽莎白一世，你知道的。可能还有阿尔弗雷德。也许是阿尔弗雷德。但我的意思是，纳尔逊比阿尔弗雷德更有名，我会这么说。是的，我想是的。
Wouldn't you? Yes. I mean, I think he's become a slightly distant figure. He's up there on his column. People don't really study the Napoleonic Wars in detail. I mean, we at school, we were close in Salisbury, we were close enough to Portsmouth that once a year we'd go to HMS Victory. I read quite a lot about him when I was a child and I found him a heroic figure. I mean,
难道不是吗？是的。我的意思是，我觉得他已经成了一个稍微有点遥远的人物。他高高站在纪念柱上。人们并没有真正详细研究拿破仑战争。我的意思是，我们在学校时，离索尔兹伯里很近，离朴次茅斯也足够近，所以每年我们都会去一次胜利号。我小时候读过很多关于他的书，我发现他是一个英雄式的人物。我的意思是，
I think he is a heroic figure. He's very, very, I mean, unbelievably physically brave. And he has the slightly chilling quality of a hero. In the first episode, we talked about him as a kind of epic. He's a kind of weird Christian Achilles might be the best way to sum him up. I mean, he's the son of a very conservative Tory clergyman. He's very, very ideologically opposed to the Jacobinism, the anti-monarchism, the republicanism of his French adversaries. He sees himself absolutely as engaged, I think, in a kind of apocalyptic battle against the French republicanism. He's a kind of weird mix of absolute attention to detail.
我认为他是一个英雄式的人物。他非常、非常——我是说，有着难以置信的肉体勇敢。并且他身上带有英雄那种略微让人不寒而栗的品质。在第一集里，我们谈到他就像是一个史诗级的人物。他有点像一个奇异的基督教阿喀琉斯，这可能是对他的最好总结。我的意思是，他是一个非常保守的托利党神职人员的儿子。在意识形态上，他非常坚决地反对雅各宾主义、反君主制主义以及他法国敌人的共和主义。我认为，他绝对把自己看作是卷入了一场针对法国共和主义的末日般的战斗。他是一个奇怪的混合体，对细节有着绝对的关注。
So we talked about that in the first episode, how important that is to the success of the Navy. So right the way through his career, he keeps a weather log. he keeps a weather log on the last you know the day he dies 21st of october 1805 and he's done that throughout his entire career and it's that that enables him to have this absolutely kind of pinpoint ability to judge the waves the winds everything that that an admiral needs to to properly read um the the
所以在第一集里我们谈到了这一点，这对于海军的成功是多么重要。因此，在他整个职业生涯中，他一直坚持记录天气日志。他在生命的最后一天（你知道的，1805年10月21日）也记着天气日志，他在整个职业生涯中都是这样做的，正是这一点让他拥有了这种绝对精准的能力去判断海浪、风向——海军上将为了正确解读
surface on which he's going to fight. But at the same time, he has this kind of strange visionary quality. So when he's 17, he goes to Central America and he gets malaria, he's recovering from it, and he feels incredibly depressed about how little he's done, even though he's aged 17 at the time. But, you know, anyone who's been 17 is perhaps aware of that kind of... And he said, I could discover no means of reaching the object of my ambition after a long and gloomy reverie in which I almost wished myself overboard. A sudden glow of patriotism was kindled within me and presented my king and country as my patron. My mind exulted in the idea. Well then,
他将要作战的战场面貌所需的一切。但与此同时，他身上又有一种奇特的富有远见的特质。所以当他17岁时，他去了中美洲，得了疟疾，在康复期间，他对自己做得这么少感到无比沮丧，尽管当时他才17岁。但是，你知道，任何经历过17岁的人可能都能体会那种……他说：“在经过长久而阴郁的沉思、甚至几乎让我产生跳海念头之后，我发现没有任何方法可以达成我的雄心壮志。一股突然的爱国热情在我心中燃起，将我的国王和国家呈现为我的守护神。我的心灵为这个想法而欢欣鼓舞。好吧，”
I exclaimed, I will be a hero. And confiding in Providence, I will brave every danger. Well, that combination of the patriotism and Providence is absolutely key to his character, isn't it, Tom? Yes, I think he literally has this kind of, he feels possessed by a kind of prophetic, a visionary fire. And that is what people respond to. People love him. Yes, but his captains adore him and he is a i mean so all of that makes him sound a bit of a monster because somebody who has that prophetic fire and all that stuff you know they can be quite as you said a terrifying figure but the interesting thing with him is he is
我大声喊道，“我将成为一名英雄。并且托庇于神意，我将勇往直前迎向所有的危险。”嗯，这种爱国主义与神意的结合是他性格的绝对关键，不是吗，汤姆？是的，我认为他字面意义上拥有这种……他觉得自己被某种预言般的、富有远见的火所附体。而这就是人们所回应的。人们爱戴他。是的，但他的舰长们崇拜他，而且他是——我是说，所有这些都让他听起来有点像个怪物，因为一个拥有这种预言之火和所有这些东西的人，你知道的，他们可能就像你说的，是一个可怕的人物；但有趣的是，他……
i mean sometimes you know there's all the you know we could do a restless history tips for american business leaders flying from cincinnati to Houston, and they don't have anything to read, and the kind of book that would be available in the airport. Well, actually, the management techniques of Horatio Nelson would be a reasonable, because he's a brilliant manager of his staff, of his underlings, isn't he? Because he gets on fantastically well with his captains. Basically, to work with Nelson was to adore him.
我的意思是，有时你知道，这一切……我们完全可以出一本《给从辛辛那提飞往休斯顿的美国商业领袖的“恢弘史诗”小贴士》，他们无书可读，机场里也找不到那种书。好吧，实际上，霍雷肖·纳尔逊的管理技术会是一个合理的选择，因为他对他的员工、他的下属是一个极其出色的管理者，不是吗？因为他和他的舰长们相处得好极了。基本上，在纳尔逊手下工作就是崇拜他。
That's what essentially everybody says. There are his peers who find him insufferable, who think he's bumptious. So a bit like with Churchill, a bit like with the young Churchill. They think he's a medal hunter. They think he's fame hungry. They think he's annoying and whingy and difficult and all those things. But the people who work for him worship him, don't they? Completely. and all those things. But the people who work for him worship him, don't they? Completely, because his charisma, his courage,
这基本上是所有人的共识。也有一些与他同级别的人觉得他令人难以忍受，认为他自负。所以有点像丘吉尔，有点像年轻时的丘吉尔。他们认为他是个勋章猎人。他们认为他渴望名声。他们认为他讨厌、爱发牢骚、难以相处，诸如此类。但为他工作的人却崇拜他，不是吗？完全如此。以及所有这些，但为他工作的人崇拜他，不是吗？完全如此，因为他的个人魅力、他的勇气，
but also the way that he obviously loves his captains and loves his men. So Adam Nicholson, who wrote a brilliant book, Men of Honour, about Trafalgar, says that the people Nelson loved, apart, of course, from Emma Hamilton, his mistress, were his captains. And I think that that sense of a band of brothers,
还有他显然热爱他的舰长和水兵的方式。因此，亚当·尼科尔森（Adam Nicholson）写了一本关于特拉法加的精彩著作《荣誉之男》（Men of Honour），他在书中说，纳尔逊所爱的人——当然，除了他的情妇埃玛·汉密尔顿之外——就是他的舰长们。我认为那种兄弟连的感觉，
you know, the great speech of Henry V, which Nelson knew off by heart, that sense that to be with Nelson was to be taking part in a great heroic epic, it absolutely animates both Nelson himself, but all his captains and the men who serve under the captains not least tom because he he because he's aware of the media you know this is an age of a media range he's a media star yes uh he he casts himself just as churchill would later do he casts himself as a kind of melodramatic hero, doesn't he?
你知道的，亨利五世那段纳尔逊烂熟于心的伟大演讲——那种与纳尔逊在一起就是参与了一场伟大英雄史诗的感觉，彻底激发了纳尔逊本人，以及他所有的舰长和在舰长们手下服役的水兵们。尤其是，汤姆，因为他——因为他有媒体意识（你知道的，这是一个媒体密集的时代），他是一个媒体明星。是的，他把自己塑造得——就像丘吉尔后来所做的那样——把自己塑造成了一种情节剧式的英雄，不是吗？
He plays up to the crowds. He plays up to the newspapers and the gossip columnists, as it were. And he communicates to the people around him. We're not just sailing off to fight the French in a sort of bog standard battle. You are characters in this, what you called a Homeric epic. And people love to be told that. And his captains love that. The men love that, don't they?
他迎合大众。他迎合报纸和八卦专栏作家。他向周围的人传达：我们不只是出海去和法国人进行一场普通烂大街的战斗。你们是这场被你称为荷马史诗中的角色。人们喜欢听这样的话。他的舰长们喜欢这样。水兵们也喜欢这样，不是吗？
I mean, I think it works on two levels. So there is the sense that Nelson himself would never ask his men to do something that he wouldn't do. So there's the famous response when he has his arm amputated after an abortive attack on Tenerife. And he's asked, you know, how are your spirits? And he replies, never better. And that's the kind of quality of sang- fit, to ensure that they're healthy. It's not just about so that they can go out and kill the French,
我的意思是，我认为这在两个层面上起作用。首先是这样一种感觉：纳尔逊本人绝不会要求他的手下去做他自己不会做的事。所以在特拉法加遭遇了一次失败的进攻而失去手臂后，有一个著名的回答。当被问及“你的精神状态如何”时，他回答：“从未这么好过。”这是一种镇定的品质，以确保他们保持健康。这不仅是为了让他们能够出去杀死法国人，
although that is absolutely a part of it, but it's also because he passionately cares about their health. And so Captain Hardy, so Nelson is the Admiral on the victory, Hardy is the captain, the flag captain, and of course famously ends up kissing Nelson as he's dying. He says of Nelson that it was not a foolish passion for fighting, for he was the most gentle of all human creatures and often lamented the cruel necessity of it. But it was a principle of duty, which all men owed their country in defense of her laws and liberty. That sense that he's simultaneously unbelievably ferocious, but also very gentle.
尽管这绝对是其中的一部分，但这也是因为他热切地关心他们的健康。因此，霍迪舰长——所以纳尔逊是胜利号上的舰队司令，霍迪是舰长、旗舰舰长，当然，他最著名的就是在纳尔逊垂死时亲吻了纳尔逊——他这样评价纳尔逊：“这不是对战斗的愚蠢狂热，因为他是所有人类中最温柔的，并且经常对这种残酷的必要性感到痛惜。但这是一种职责原则，是所有人为了捍卫祖国的法律和自由而欠国家的。”那种他既有着不可思议的凶猛、又同时非常温柔的感觉。
And that's something that you get with other captains as well so um probably uh aside from nelson the most celebrated um admiral in the napoleonic wars is cuthbert cullingwood who is a big big uh hero for uh dan jackson from newcastle uh newcastle man yes so he's called cuthbert his brother is called Wilfred so clearly drawing on the names of the great Northumbrian saints and and they were friends from young men they served together in their early years in the navy and both Nelson and Collingwood adored animals so Nelson was very very keen on on animals Collingwood famously had a dog called Bounce which he kept with him on his ship um and And when Nelson arrived at Trafalgar to consult with Collingwood,
这也是你在其他舰长身上能看到的特质，所以……可能除了纳尔逊之外，拿破仑战争中最著名的海军将领是卡思伯特·科林伍德（Cuthbert Collingwood），他是纽卡斯尔的丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）心目中的超级大英雄，纽卡斯尔人，是的。所以他叫卡思伯特，他的兄弟叫威尔弗雷德，显然是借鉴了诺森比亚伟大圣徒的名字。他们从年轻时起就是朋友，在海军早期的岁月中一起服役。纳尔逊和科林伍德都非常喜欢动物——所以纳尔逊非常、非常喜欢动物，科林伍德有一只著名的狗叫“弹跳”（Bounce），他把它带在船上随身饲养；
Bounce was there on the ship with him. He loves animals. He's charismatic. He kills the French. He behaves like a film star. He cares for people. This is a kind of package that people can really respond to. There's a wonderful moment, Tom.
当纳尔逊抵达特拉法加与科林伍德商议时，“弹跳”就在船上陪着他。他热爱动物。他极具个人魅力。他消灭法国人。他举止像个电影明星。他关怀他人。这是一种人们能够真正产生共鸣的组合。有一个绝妙的时刻，汤姆。
I know you have a horror of this franchise franchise but in the film master and commander i love the master and commander russell crowe's character is asked they're all sitting he's with he's got the midshipmen who are the the young boys who are kind of training to be officers um around him one of them says did you ever meet lord nelson sir and he says at one point i had that honor i had that honor yeah I had that honor. He makes a joke about Nelson asking him to pass the salt. But then, and they all laugh. And then he says, the thing that sticks in his mind is that somebody offered Nelson a coat because it was cold.
我知道你对这个系列电影有些惊恐，但在电影《怒海争锋》中——我很喜欢《怒海争锋》——罗素·克劳饰演的角色被问到（他们正坐在一起，周围都是正在接受培训成为军官的年轻男孩——见习水兵），其中一个问道：“阁下，您见过纳尔逊勋爵吗？”他说：“我有过那种荣幸，我有过那种荣幸，是的，我有过那种荣幸。”他开了个玩笑，说纳尔逊让他递一下盐。然后，他们都笑了。接着他说，留在他脑海中的一件事是，有人给纳尔逊递了一件外套，因为天冷。
And Nelson said, I don't need a coat because my love of king and country keep me warm. And Russell Crowe's character, Captain Aubrey, says, from anybody else you would say this was pretty poor stuff, but when it came from Nelson, you knew he meant it. And there's just a silence in the cabin. It's a wonderful scene. And actually what that captures was exactly what people did feel about Nelson, that he would come out with these kind of what you might say are hallmark sentiments about king and country,
而纳尔逊说：“我不需要外套，因为我对国王和祖国的爱温暖着我。”罗素·克劳饰演的角色、奥布里舰长说：“换作别人，你会觉得这实在是很空洞的漂亮话，但当这话出自纳尔逊之口时，你知道他是认真的。”船舱里顿时一片寂静。这是一个精彩的场景。而实际上，这恰恰捕捉到了人们对纳尔逊的真实感受——他会说出这些你可能会说是关于国王和国家的标准感言，
but he said it with such charisma and passion and much as i suppose you would say churchill did in 1940 that people would be wiping away people like tom holland would be wiping away manly tears of uh of patriotic passion tom say something negative about nelson so that people listen to this podcast won't lambast us for being um is there is there any counter argument to all this? Or do you think he's beyond counter-arguments? Do you know, emotionally, I do feel that. I think because he was a kind of childhood hero
但他带着如此巨大的个人魅力和激情说出来——就像你在1940年对丘吉尔的评价一样——人们会擦去……像汤姆·霍兰这样的人会擦去充满爱国激情的纯爷们儿的眼泪。汤姆，说点纳尔逊的负面内容吧，免得听这个播客的人抨击我们太……有没有什么针对这一切的反面论点？还是你觉得他已经超出了反面论点的范畴？你知道，从情感上讲，我的确有这种感觉。我想，因为他是一个童年时期的英雄，
and the emotions one feels as a child are much harder to kind of purge often. I feel much more strongly about Nelson than I do about, say, Churchill. I don't really care about Churchillill what people say about churchill right but i suppose one would say about nelson is that um he spends a lot of time in the caribbean uh as as we will come on to this he does in the last year of his life as we'll come to discuss he he was very hostile to abolitionism um he wasn't an admirer of wilberforce at no point does he express any anxiety about the source of britain's wealth that is extracting from the caribbean so i think that that is uh something to be that that in the 21st century would be marked down against him just as
而作为一个孩子所感受到的情感，通常要难得多去清除。比起丘吉尔，我对纳尔逊有着更强烈的情感。我其实并不在乎别人对丘吉尔说些什么，对吧？但我想人们对纳尔逊会说的是，嗯……他在加勒比海度过了大量时间——正如我们接下来要谈到的那样。在他生命的最后一年里，正如我们将要讨论的那样，他对废奴主义非常敌视；他不是威廉·威尔伯福斯的崇拜者；他从未对英国财富的来源（即从加勒比海的掠夺）表露过任何不安。所以我想，这是在21世纪会被记在他黑账上的一点，就像
in the 19th century in the victorian period his relationship with emma hamilton yeah so he does have a pretty rackety love life i I think it's fair to say. He does. So he marries actually the daughter of a planter. And she doesn't really measure up to Nelson's sense of what the wife of a hero should be like. Whereas Emma Hamilton, who's this extraordinary woman, who is the wife of the British ambassador to Naples,
在19世纪的维多利亚时期，他与埃玛·汉密尔顿的关系一样……是的，他的情史确实相当混乱，我觉得这么说很公平。确实如此。所以他实际上娶了一个种植园主的女儿。而她并不符合纳尔逊心中英雄妻子的标准。相比之下，埃玛·汉密尔顿这位非凡的女性——她是英国驻那不勒斯大使的妻子，
who becomes embroiled with Nelson, both romantically and all kinds of wars and shenanigans and rebellions that are going on in Southern Italy at the time, and ends up living with Nelson in Merton. And this is seen by the Victorians as being a great black mark against him. I think less so by his contemporaries, actually. I think that was seen as, I i mean this was the age of the prince regent um the man who'll become william the fourth and mrs jordan so this is kind of much more powerful the cause but you know he has his insecurities he he's he's a driven man and he is the great object in his life is is essentially to kill and destroy as many of the enemy as possible.
她与纳尔逊陷入了纠葛，不仅有浪漫恋情，还卷入了当时意大利南部发生的各种战争、阴谋和叛乱，最后和纳尔逊一起住在默顿。这在维多利亚时代的人看来是他身上一个巨大的污点。事实上，在同时代人看来可能没那么严重。我认为这被视为……我的意思是，这是摄政王时代，也就是后来成为威廉四世的那位以及约旦夫人的时代，所以这更像是……但你知道的，他有他的不安全感，他是一个受驱使的人，他生命中的伟大目标本质上就是尽可能多地杀死和消灭敌人。
I mean, as I say, there is a strong element of the Achilles within him. He's extraordinarily aggressive, isn't he? So very famously, you mentioned in the last episode, Capes and Vincent. That's the one where he had led his men in a boarding party, the first British captain to do this, the English captain since the 16th century, onto the San Nicola. He had led them brilliantly with the war cry, Westminster Abbey or glorious victory, i.e. death or victory. But I mean, you can imagine if you've got a captain who is leading you, shouting that, waving his gun or his cutlass or whatever,
正如我所说，他内心有着强烈的阿喀琉斯成分。他异常好战，不是吗？所以非常著名的是，你上集提到了圣文森特角。那是他率领敢死队员登敌舰的地方，是自16世纪以来第一位这样做的英国（或称英格兰）船长，登上了“圣尼古拉号”。他带着“威斯特敏斯特教堂或光荣胜利”（即不成功便成仁）的战斗口号，极其出色地领导了他们。但我的意思是，你可以想象，如果你有一个船长正领导着你，大喊着这个口号，挥舞着他的枪或短剑或别的什么，
you just think, fantastic, don't you? I mean, you can see why the men would respond to that. Yes. And what's interesting about the fleet at Trafalgar is that actually, although Nelson's very keen on the idea of the Band of Brothers, he doesn't know huge amounts of the people who end up serving with him at Trafalgar. But in the very few, you know, the brief space of time that he is there, he forges them again into this kind of collective force that is able to brave incredible dangers. We'll come on to discuss. And we talked in the first episode how the Royal Navy is perhaps the preeminent British institution. So I think a third of the sailors
你只会觉得：太棒了，不是吗？我的意思是，你能理解为什么手下的人会对此作出回应。是的。而关于特拉法加舰队有趣的是，尽管纳尔逊非常热衷于“兄弟连”的想法，但他其实并不十分了解那些最终在特拉法加与他并肩作战的人。但在极短的时间里——他呆在那里的短暂时间内——他再次将他们锻造成了一支能够勇往直前、面对难以想象的危险的集体力量。我们接下来会讨论。我们在第一集里谈过，皇家海军或许是英国最卓越的机构。所以我想，有三分之一的水兵
at Trafalgar come from Ireland. You have about 1500 are born outside Britain and Ireland uh you've got I've got figures here got 373 from the US 136 from Italy uh amazingly you've got 57 from France I guess they're kind of royalists um famously you have 18 from Africa so one of them is shown on the um the frieze uh at the base of Nelson's column. Yeah, we talked about that in our statues episode, didn't we? Yes, yeah. A man called George Ryan, who was 23 at the Battle of Trafalgar. And Nelson gets all of them behind him, I think.
在特拉法加战役中来自爱尔兰。大约有1500人出生在英国和爱尔兰以外；我这里有数字，有373人来自美国，136人来自意大利，令人惊奇的是还有57人来自法国——我猜他们算是保王党吧；著名的还有18人来自非洲，其中一人被雕刻在纳尔逊纪念柱底座的浮雕上。是的，我们在雕像那一集里谈过，对吧？是的，一个名叫乔治·莱恩（George Ryan）的人，他在特拉法加战役时23岁。而纳尔逊让所有这些人紧随其后，我认为，
So I think that's the measure of nelson now his opponent at trafalgar a less impressive figure i think it's fair to say but a man who is he has a hard gig he's got a huge name tom i mean say that for you do you want to give us the name well his name is pierre charles jean baptiste sylvester villeneuve but it would be even longer if you hadn't dropped the de. So it was de Villeneuve. So he's an aristocrat, Tom, isn't he? Yes. Now, has he sold out or is he just patriotic and he's doing his best for France, despite the fact that there's a Republican regime
这就是纳尔逊的尺度。现在，他在特拉法加的对手是一个不那么令人印象深刻的人物，这么说算公允，但他接手了一项艰难的工作。汤姆，他有一个极长的名字——这么说吧。你想给我们报一下他的名字吗？好吧，他的名字叫皮埃尔·夏尔·让-巴蒂斯特·西尔维斯特·德·维尔纳夫（Pierre Charles Jean Baptiste Silvestre de Villeneuve），但如果你没有漏掉那个“de”，它还会更长。所以那是德·维尔纳夫。因此，汤姆，他是个贵族，不是吗？是的。现在，他是背叛了，还是仅仅出于爱国主义，在无视共和政权的情况下为法国尽其所能？
or what's going on with Villeneuve? So the French Navy before the revolution is a very aristocratic institution. And that's the contrast with the British system. And when the French revolution happens, basically, the entire command structure gets eliminated. And this is why the French Navy is in a terrible state throughout the early Revolutionary Wars. And it's obviously brilliant for the Royal Navy. It's a massive contrib this hasn't been entirely helpful and so uh to an extent there's a kind of amnesty offered to royalist officers um i think villeneuve is a as a patriot uh he recognizes that um you know the king is gone he wants to serve france i mean he really is unbelievably aristocrat so he um he was a knight of malta he'd had an ancestor who'd
或者维尔纳夫身上到底发生了什么？大革命前的法国海军是一个非常贵族的机构。这与英国体制形成了鲜明对比。当法国大革命爆发时，基本上整个指挥结构都被消灭了。这就是为什么法国海军在整个早期革命战争期间都处于可怕的状态。这显然对皇家海军大有裨益。这是一个巨大的贡献，但这并没有完全帮到忙，所以……在某种程度上，对保王党军官提供了一种特赦；我认为维尔纳夫是一个爱国者，他认识到……你知道，国王已经不在了，他想要为法国效力。我的意思是，他确实是一个不可思议的贵族——他曾是马耳他骑士团骑士，他的祖先曾在隆塞斯瓦尔斯战役（《罗兰之歌》中查理曼大帝那场战役）中作战，还有一个祖先参加过十字军东征。在1805年，他很可能是拿破仑手下最有效的海军上将，但这并不意味着他有多么高效。他在尼罗河战役中遭遇过纳尔逊并逃脱了，所以他曾直视过纳尔逊的眼睛。因此，对于那些不知道的人来说，尼罗河战役是拿破仑去到埃及的时候，
fought at the Battle of Roncesvalles, the Song of Roland, Charlemagne and all that, an ancestor who fought in the Crusades. And he's probably in 1805, the most effective admiral that Napoleon has, but that doesn't make him very effective. He's run up nelson at uh the battle of the nile and he escaped that so he's he's he's stared into the whites of uh nelson's eyes so the battle of the nile for people who don't know that was when napoleon had gone over to egypt um nelson had kind of caught up with him and fought this tremendous battle cornering the French, and had basically broken Napoleon's attempt to take Egypt as the sort of gateway to India and so on. And is that right, Tom?
纳尔逊追上了他，并发起了这场巨大的战役，将法军逼入绝境，基本上粉碎了拿破仑试图将埃及作为通往印度的门户等等的企图。是这样吗，汤姆？是的。尼罗河战役是纳尔逊式进攻的一个经典例子。所以他在傍晚时分带着舰队出现。他没有停顿。他直接开船绕到了法国舰队的后方，尽管水非常浅，这是一个风险极大的战术动作。然后他把法军炸成了碎片。这是纳尔逊的第一场伟大的歼灭战。他摧毁了两艘船，俘获了九艘。这远远超过了任何人在此前革命战争和拿破仑战争中与法国交战时所取得的成果。这树立了一个先例：在特拉法加，他是有意识地试图超越这一成就。他有意识地试图对法国人实施歼灭战。维尔纳夫深知这一点。基本上，他在尼罗河被击溃了，
Yes. And the Battle of the Nile is a classic example of Nelsonian aggression. So he turns up with his fleet late in the afternoon. He doesn't pause. He just sails straight in around the back of the French fleet, even though the waters are very shallow and it's a very risky maneuver. And he blasts them out of the water. And this is Nelson's first great battle of annihilation. He destroys two ships, he captures nine. And that is far more than anyone has done in any engagement with the French in the Revolutionary and Napoleonic Wars. And it kind of sets a precedent that at Trafalgar, he's consciously trying to exceed that. He's consciously trying to practice a battle of annihilation against the French. And Will knows this. And essentially, he's been broken at the Nile
并且被英国的海上霸权展示所击溃。因此他写信给他的朋友丹尼斯·德克雷（Denis Decrès），后者基本上就是海军事务大臣，他也曾参加过尼罗河战役。他在1805年写信给他说：“当双方势均力敌时，我们根本不可能击败敌人。事实上，当我们的实力比他们弱三分之一时，他们就会击败我们。”这听起来可能像是失败主义，或者你也可以说这是现实主义。但维尔纳夫……你知道，他没有那种纳尔逊带到战场上的傲慢与自信，西班牙人同样也没有。西班牙人是一支更加老式的海军，这样说很公平吧？他们是一支旧制度海军，
and he's been broken by the displays of British naval supremacy. And so he writes to a friend of his, Denis Decret, who is essentially the Minister for Naval Affairs, who had also been at the Battle of the Nile. And he writes to him in 1805, it is utterly impossible for us to defeat the enemy when both sides are equal. Indeed, they will beat us when they are a third weaker than we are. And that may sound like defeatism, or you may say that that's realism. But Villeneuve is is you know he's not possessed of the the swagger and the confidence certainly that Nelson is bringing to the table nor it has to be said are the Spanish who are Spanish are much more they're much more old-fashioned navy that's fair to say isn't it they're an ancient regime navy
没有现代化，也没有达到哪怕接近那种程度的专业化？嗯，不完全是。所以西班牙舰队，显然，你知道，它拥有可追溯到16世纪的伟大航海传统。对大西洋的控制对西班牙帝国至关重要，但它在18世纪被摧毁了。在此之后的几十年里，一直持续到特拉法加时期，西班牙政府一直集中精力试图对舰队重新进行再投资。因为他们认识到，如果没有这一点，西班牙就根本没有资格自称是一个大国。因此在1720年代，有一位海军大臣叫马勒帕伯爵（Comte de Maurepas）。他说，贸易创造财富，从而创造国家的权力。
not modernized not professionalized to anything like the same degree? Well, not entirely. So the Spanish fleet, obviously, you know, it has that great tradition of seafaring going back to the 16th century. And control of the Atlantic is crucial to the Spanish empire, but it gets destroyed in the 18th century. And then in the decades that follow that, so building up to the time of Trafalgar, there's been a concentrated attempt by the Spanish government to reinvest in the fleet. Because they recognize that without that, Spain has no pretensions whatsoever to being a great power. So in the 1720s, there's a naval minister called the Comte de Maripaz. And he says trade generates the wealth, consequently the power of states.
海军对于维持海上贸易是绝对必要的。但是，汤姆，你知道纳尔逊是怎么评价西班牙人的吗？我当然知道。“老爷们可以造出精良的船只，但他们造不出水兵。”不过在这里，他并不是说——他并不是说他们不是人，说他们是会逃跑的懦夫。这实际上是对人口统计学的一个评论。西班牙面临的一个法国和英国所没有的问题是，西班牙从加勒比海和新世界重新输入了疾病。
Navies are absolutely necessary to sustain seaborne trade. But Tom, you know what Nelson said of the Spanish? I do. The dons may make fine ships. They cannot, however, make men. But there, he's not saying that, you know, he's not kind of saying they're not men, that they're, you know, they're cowards who run away. It's literally a comment about the demographics. And one of the problems that Spain faces that France and Britain doesn't is that Spain has reimported diseases from the Caribbean and the New World.
所以黄热病在1805年西班牙南部的加的斯等地肆虐。这给西班牙为其舰船配备人员的能力带来了可怕的连锁反应。因此，法国最高指挥部是失败主义的。西班牙最高指挥部则意识到在战斗中缺乏人力，对与法国结盟感到非常、非常的矛盾。我的意思是，本质上它在法国的霸凌和英国的霸凌之间撕裂。西班牙在战争初期曾与英国交战。1801年《亚眠条约》战争结束，当英法恢复战争时，西班牙没有重新参战。但在1804年，他们确实重新参战了。原因在于有一支西班牙
So yellow fever is raging, say, in Cádiz in southern Spain in 1805. And that has a terrible kind of knock-on effect on the ability of Spain to man its ships. So the French high command is defeatist. The Spanish high command is aware that it lacks the manpower in a battle and is very, very ambivalent about siding with France. I mean, essentially, it's kind's torn between French bullying and British bullying. Spain had fought against Britain in the early stages of the war. 1801, the Treaty of Amiens, the war ends, doesn't re-enter the war when Britain and France resume the war. But then in 1804, they do re-enter the war. The reason for that is that there is a Spanish
珍宝船队遭到英国袭击。在珍宝船队上还有许多妇女和平民，其中许多人在交战中丧生。这在全欧洲被普遍视为战争罪行。这意味着西班牙基本上别无选择，只能重新参战。但他们仍然非常勉强。西班牙最高指挥部内部仍然存在着相当亲英的倾向。而且至关重要的是，对于在1805年开始发展的战役来说，西班牙不会允许他们的舰船加入法国并进入英吉利海峡。所以西班牙并没有把这一点告诉法国，但西班牙政府已经向西班牙最高指挥部下达了指示：你们不得随法国人前往。
treasure fleet and the British attack it. And on board the treasure fleet, there are also lots of women and civilians, and a lot of them get killed in the engagement. And this is widely seen across Europe as a war crime. And it means that the Spanish essentially have no alternative but to reenter the war. But they're still very reluctant. There is still quite an Anglophile strain within the Spanish high command. And crucially, for the campaign that starts to develop in 1805, the Spanish are not going to allow their ships to join the French and go into the Channel. So the Spanish have not told the French that, but the Spanish high command have been told by the government, you are not to go with the French.
所以基本上，这就是指挥官们和水兵们的现状。我想中场休息后，我们应该回来看看这在特拉法加战役实际爆发前的酝酿阶段是如何演变的。所以最后，汤姆，在这场史诗般的节目进行了一个半小时后，我们正在接近……好吧，我们正在接近1805年。不管怎样，我不会说我们正在接近特拉法加。所以最后，汤姆，在这场史诗般的节目进行了一个半小时后。我们正在接近……好吧，我们正在接近1805年。不管怎样，我不会说我们正在接近特拉法加，因为我不想给人们过高的期望。但如果你在休息后回来，我们至少会身处
So essentially, that's the state of play with the commanders and the men. And I think after the break, we should come back and we should look at how this plays out in the build-up to the actual Battle of Trafalgar. So finally, Tom, an hour and a half into this epic, we're approaching, well, we're approaching 1805. Anyway, I won't say we're approaching Trafalgar. So finally, Tom, an hour and a half into this epic. We're approaching, well, we're approaching 1805. Anyway, I won't say we're approaching Trafalgar because I don't want to get people's hopes up. But if you come back after the break, we'll at least be in the
正确的年份。那么我们一会儿见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，
right year. So we'll see you then. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。所以，我知道你一直在……我看着你呢，你把中场休息的时间都用来捣弄你那堆庞大的笔记了。我希望我没有揭开太多的面纱，因为正如你对听众所说的那样，你已经读了海量的书。是的，我只是想把这一点……所以你完全准备好为我们对拿破仑战争直到特拉法加战役进程进行大师级的战略概述了。所以汤姆，我们现在身处何地，到底发生了什么？好吧，还记得我们第一集开头的人……
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, know you have been you've spent the break i've watched you you've spent the break interfering with your colossal pile of notes i i hope i'm not drawing back the veil too much to say that i mean you've done colossal amounts of reading as you've told the listeners yeah i just want that on the. So you're absolutely poised to give us a masterly strategic overview of the course of the war up to the Battle of Trafalgar. So Tom, where are we and what is going on? Well, people who remember the beginning of our first episode. Six hours ago. We talked about Napoleon's plans to invade Britain. This is the context. He has built up an enormous force
六个小时前。我们谈到了拿破仑入侵英国的计划。这就是背景。他在法国北部海岸、以滨海布洛涅为中心集结了一支庞大的军队。他需要把它运过英吉利海峡。为此，他需要击退英国舰队。所以他基本上需要控制英吉利海峡哪怕极短的一段时间。他实现这一计划的战略，是将他在陆战中惯常使用的伎俩——即制造佯攻、转移敌人视线使他们看向一个方向，然后他再发动突击——在大西洋的规模上复制一遍。他有各种各样的舰队被英国对法国和西班牙港口的封锁所困住，这些港口里有许多舰船，如果能把它们集中起来，就会形成一支庞大的舰队，从而有可能在数量上压倒英国在英吉利海峡的舰队。所以总计，西班牙和法国，他们大约有一百艘船，我想大概有一百艘战列舰。是的。所以这些港口有：布洛涅，被一个叫基斯的人（基思海军上将）率领的英国舰队封锁着；
on the North French coast, centered around Boulogne. He needs to get it across the Channel. And to do that, he needs to beat off the British fleet. So he needs essentially to take control of the Channel only for a very short space of time. His plan for doing this is to repeat on the scale of the Atlantic what he conventionally does in land battles, which is to create feints and to distract the enemy so that they're looking one way and then he strikes in. He has various fleets that are kind of bottled up by British blockades. of French and Spanish ports that contain ships that if they can be brought together will create a concentrated fleet that potentially will have the chance to outnumber the British fleet in the channel. So in total, Spanish and French, they've got about 100 ships, I think about 100 ships at the line. Yeah. And so these ports are, you've got Boulogne, the British fleet under a guy called Keith, Admiral Keith. So that's blockaded. You have Brest in just kind of southern side of the tip of Brittany, which is blockaded. You have the port of Rochefort lower down. You have Ferrol in northern Spain. You have Cadiz in southern Spain, just above Trafalgar, just above Gibraltar, which is occupied by Britain. And then you have Toulon, which is the great naval base in the south of France, which is blockaded by Nelson. Napoleon's plan is that
布雷斯特（Brest），位于布列塔尼半岛尖端的南部，被封锁着；再往下有罗什福尔（Rochefort）港；西班牙北部的费罗尔（Ferrol）；西班牙南部、特拉法加上方、直布罗陀上方（被英国占领）的加的斯（Cadiz）；然后是土伦（Toulon），法国南部的巨大海军基地，被纳尔逊封锁着。拿破仑的计划是：
the force in Toulon, which is commanded by Villeneuve, will slip out, give Nelson the slip, sail out through the Straits of Gibraltar, and head out to the Caribbean. And the Caribbean is so economically important to Britain. It's, you know, the center of sugar and tobacco and cotton, and of course, of slaves. I mean, slaves themselves are incredibly valuable property. And that will drag Nelson out, is the plan. But the Atlantic is so huge that Villeneuve will meet with forces that have come from Rochefort and from the Spanish ports. And they will then move up into the channel. So they'll double back. They'll double back.
由维尔纳夫指挥的土伦兵力将溜出来，甩掉纳尔逊，从直布罗陀海峡驶出，驶向加勒比海。而加勒比海对英国的经济至关重要。它是（你知道的）糖、烟草、棉花，当然还有奴隶的中心。我的意思是，奴隶本身就是极其宝贵的财产。按照计划，这将会把纳尔逊引出去。但大西洋太巨大了，以至于维尔纳夫将与来自罗什福尔和西班牙港口的兵力汇合。然后他们将北上进入英吉利海峡。所以他们会折返。他们会折返。
And Nelson will have no idea what's going on because the vastness of the Atlantic means it's very difficult to keep track of it. So that is the plan. It's an incredibly complicated plan. And I think it reflects the fact that napoleon has never actually commanded at sea because he's assuming that all the things that can go wrong all the rendezvous that will be missed storms all yes exactly so it's a very very complicated plan but but this is what his his aim is let's say the plan works so villeneuve and the spanish they double back they get back they relieve brest they they join up with the rest and the Spanish they double back, they get back they relieve Brest
而纳尔逊将完全不知道发生了什么，因为大西洋的浩瀚意味着很难对其行踪进行追踪。这就是那个计划。这是一个极其复杂的计划。我认为这反映出拿破仑从未真正在海上指挥过，因为他假设所有可能出错的事情——所有错过的会合点、风暴等等，是的，完全如此——所以这是一个非常、非常复杂的计划。但这就是他的目标。假设这个计划成功了：维尔纳夫和西班牙人折返了，他们回去了，他们解除了对布雷斯特的封锁，他们与舰队的其余部分汇合了，他们去到布洛涅，他们把部队接上……
they join up with the rest of the fleet they go to Boulogne, they get the troops how many troops are there? 150,000? 100,000? Something like that and then they ferry them, they manage to break Admiral Keith, get the men across the channel and then their plan, we were talking about this in episode one, their plan is
有多少部队？十五万？十万？差不多吧。然后他们用船运送他们，他们成功突破了基斯海军上将的防线，把士兵运过了海峡，然后他们的计划——我们在第一集里讨论过——他们的计划
really it's destruction rather than occupation. Yes, it's to destroy the underpinnings of British naval power. So to destroy the bases at Portsmouth and Plymouth and up the Thames Estuary. And to some listeners, that will be like, well, who cares? It's just a raid on a few bases. But to give people a sense of the stakes, if that plan had worked, Britain would have been unable effectively to compete yeah in the napoleon
实际上是摧毁而非占领。是的，是为了摧毁英国海上力量的基础。也就是摧毁朴次茅斯、普利茅斯以及泰晤士河口基地的设施。对某些听众来说，这听起来像是：“好吧，谁在乎呢？这不过是对几个基地的突袭罢了。”但为了让人们对利害关系有一个概念，如果那个计划成功了，英国在拿破仑战争中将无法有效地竞争，
because we have no really sizable army it would have destroyed the british empire yeah it would have massively inhibited the industrial revolution well britain would have lost all its colonies conceivably certainly it's caribbean it's prized caribbean colonies the french would have been able to blockade us you know starve us out or whatever i mean in the long run the success of that Napoleonic enterprise probably would mean the diminution of Britain as a world power with enormous consequences going into the 19th century. Yes. So the stakes are very, very high. That's what makes this kind of incredible chess game that starts to evolve in the early months of 1805 so significant.
因为我们没有真正规模庞大的陆军，它会摧毁大英帝国。是的，它会极大地阻碍工业革命。好吧，英国将失去它所有的殖民地，可以想象，绝对会失去它珍视的加勒比海殖民地，法国人将能够封锁我们（你知道的，把我们围困至死等等）。我的意思是，从长远来看，拿破仑这一宏图伟业的成功可能意味着英国作为世界大国的衰落，并对进入19世纪产生巨大的后果。是的。所以利害关系非常、非常高。这就是为什么在1805头几个月开始展开的这场令人难以置信的博弈显得如此意义重大。
So what happens is that Villeneuve gets his orders from Napoleon in early January. Off you go. So he sets off on the 18th of January and he's taking his 11 battleships with him. He's got 6,000 troops. So like the Romans, it's this idea that, you know, you're going to fight land battles at sea.
所以发生的情况是，维尔纳夫在1月上旬接到了拿破仑的命令。出发吧。于是他在1月18日动身，带上了他的11艘战列舰。他有6000名士兵。就像罗马人一样，这是一种理念，你知道的，你打算在海上进行陆战。
You pack your ships with troops because that hopefully can kind of counterbalance British command of gunnery. Nelson realises that Villeneuve has gone and panics, immediately thinks of India because that's what had happened before when Napoleon had slipped out from Toulon and ended up in Egypt. So Nelson goes herring off to Alexandria. Meanwhile, Villeneuve has been beaten back into Toulon by a storm. So he's holed up in Toulon. He sets off again in March. By the 9th of April, he has reached Gibraltar. Meanwhile, Nelson is herring back from Alexandria because he's discovered the French have not got there. And on the 16th of April, he is told that Villeneuve has already passed through
你的战舰上挤满了士兵，因为这有望在某种程度上抗衡英国人的炮术。纳尔逊意识到维尔纳夫已经离开并惊慌失措，立刻想到了印度，因为以前拿破仑从土伦溜走并最终到达埃及就是这种情况。于是纳尔逊急忙赶往亚历山大。与此同时，维尔纳夫被一场风暴击退回了土伦。所以他躲在土伦。他在3月再次出发。到4月9日，他已经到达直布罗陀。与此同时，纳尔逊正从亚历山大匆忙赶回，因为他发现法国人并没有去那里。4月16日，有人告诉他维尔纳夫已经通过了
the Straits of Gibraltar. And he feels terrible feels terrible it was his job to stop this happening and he's failed and he doesn't know where villeneuve is going is villeneuve going to to ireland always a possibility the french could ferment a you know a new rebellion in ireland and that would be disastrous for britain once again if he goes to the channel that's bad if he goes to the carib that's bad. If he goes to the Caribbean, that's probably the worst case scenario in some sense, isn't it? Because the colonies are so important economically. Yes. And Nelson has to kind of take a punt. Where am I going to go? And where might he have gone? And he's so anxious by it that he's kind of prostrated. He becomes ill with anxiety. By early May, it's become clear to him from various reports have come back to him
直布罗陀海峡。他感到非常糟糕，感觉糟透了，阻止这件事发生是他的职责，而他失败了，他不知道维尔纳夫要去哪里，维尔纳夫是要去爱尔兰吗？法国人在爱尔兰煽动一场新叛乱始终是有可能的，如果那样的话对英国来说将是又一次灾难。如果他去英吉利海峡，那就糟了；如果他去加勒比海，那也很糟。如果他去加勒比海，从某种意义上说，这可能是最糟糕的情况，不是吗？因为这些殖民地在经济上太重要了。是的。纳尔逊不得不碰碰运气。我要去哪里？他可能去了哪里？他为此感到无比焦虑，以至于快要垮掉了。他因焦虑而生病。到5月上旬，从传回他的各种报告中，他已经清楚地看出
that Villeneuve is indeed heading for the Caribbean. British ships are much faster because they're much more effective at kind of clearing all the rubbish off the base of the ships. The barnacles. The barnacles. And so he goes speeding off to the West Indies
维尔纳夫确实正驶向加勒比海。英国军舰要快得多，因为它们在清除船底的所有垃圾方面要有效得多。藤壶。藤壶。因此，他风驰电掣般地驶向西印度群岛
and he arrives there shortly after Villeneuve has arrived. But Villeneuve has, first of all, failed to complete the rendezvous with the other ships. I warned him a few sentences ago. Absolutely. And also, when he knows that Nelson is on his heels, he gets thrown into a panic and flees. And he doesn't really commit you know
并在维尔纳夫到达后不久抵达那里。但是维尔纳夫首先未能与其它船只完成会合。我几句前就警告过他了。绝对是的。而且，当他知道纳尔逊紧追不舍时，他陷入了惊慌并逃跑了。他并没有真正投入，你知道的
he doesn't succeed in capturing kingston or uh antigua or whatever right and so he he heads back across the atlantic nelson has failed to corner villeneuve so he's disappointed about that but he's he he you know he's he's starting to get his confidence back. So he writes and says, I have saved these colonies and more than 200 sail of sugar-loaded ships. So he recognizes he is fighting for the sugar barons as well as for Britain. I mean, Britain can't fight the war without the money from this stuff. So he's in the Caribbean. Villeneuve is heading back across the Atlantic. By this point, everybody else is back in port um and the the british blockades have resumed outside breast
他没有成功攻占金斯敦或安提瓜之类的目标，对吧？于是他带着船队折返横渡大西洋。纳尔逊未能把维尔纳夫逼入绝境，所以他对此感到失望，但他开始重新树立信心。因此他写信说：“我拯救了这些殖民地以及200多艘装载糖类的船只。”所以他意识到他既是在为英国而战，也是在为糖业权贵而战。我的意思是，没有这些东西带来的资金，英国就无法打这场战争。所以他在加勒比海。维尔纳夫正带着船队折返横渡大西洋。此时此刻，其他所有人都回到了港口，英国人在布雷斯特外
outside rochefort outside farol and outside it is the only pieces that are really kind of moving on the the great atlantic chessboard are nelson and villeneuve um what are they going to do villeneuve heads back to uh to farol um and the a his his the plan is that he will go to farol he will pick up the spanish ships there uh he will then join the french squadron from rochefort and he will head north to the channel those are the orders that he has from Napoleon. All kinds of things prevent him from doing that. The first is that although Villeneuve doesn't know it, the Spanish have been told not to go to the channel. So there's no way the Spanish are going to accompany him. He's then sailing northwards. He runs into a British fleet under a guy called Sir Robert Calder. uh there is a battle calder fails
罗什福尔外、费罗尔外以及其他地方重新恢复了海上封锁。在大西洋的巨型棋盘上，唯一真正在移动的棋子是纳尔逊和维尔纳夫。他们要做什么？维尔纳夫返回费罗尔，他的计划是去费罗尔，在那里接上西班牙舰队，然后与来自罗什福尔的法国分舰队汇合，并向北驶向英吉利海峡。这就是他从拿破仑那里得到的命令。各种各样的事情阻止了他这样做。首先是，虽然维尔纳夫并不知道，但西班牙人已经被告知不要去英吉利海峡。所以西班牙人绝不可能陪他去。然后他向北航行。他碰巧遇到了一支由罗伯特·考尔德爵士率领的英国舰队。发生了一场战斗，考尔德未能
to destroy vilna's fleet so it's an indecisive battle and in due course calder will be pilloried for this rather like admiral bing he will it will be seen that he's been insufficiently aggressive but vilna is unsettled by this he starts to think without the i can't take the spanish with me because by now he's kind of realized the spanish aren't going to come with him he thinks that there are huge squadrons of british ships kind of between him and the channel and that they will have the beating of him and he thinks the best thing to do therefore is not to risk the french navy but to try and get back to a safe port and so he heads south down the coast of spain and he heads towards cadiz cadiz is blocked by cuthbert collingwood this very very yeah nelson's old mate
消灭维尔纳夫的舰队，所以这是一场没有分出胜负的战斗。不久之后，考尔德将为此遭到严厉谴责，有点像英格比海军上将，人们会认为他不够激进。但维尔纳夫对此感到心神不定，他开始认为，由于他现在已经意识到西班牙人不会跟他走，没有他们我就无法带上西班牙人，他认为有庞大的英国舰队横亘在他和英吉利海峡之间，他们会打败他。因此他认为最好的做法不是拿法国海军冒险，而是试着返回一个安全的港口。于是他沿着西班牙海岸向南驶去，驶向加的斯。加的斯被库珀·科林伍德封锁着，就是那个非常非常——是的，纳尔逊的老搭档
owner of bounce the dog very very tough character uh in body and mind he was iron and very cold iron but he doesn't have many shit he only has about three ships and so the risk for collingwood is that as villeneuve is coming down the coast he might get trapped between those ships that are already in um in french ships that are already in cadiz and spanish ships that are in cadiz and villeneuve's force so he retreats um he summons back more ships and he kind of hovers around on the horizon not wanting the french to know how few ships he has but the blockade continues and villeneuve ends up in cadiz and villeneuve has 33 ships or so he has yes 33 ships and napoleon feels that this is enough if he picks up more ships from from rochefort
那只叫“弹跳”的狗的主人，一个身体和精神上都非常非常顽强的硬汉。他是铁打的，冷酷如铁。但他没有多少船，他只有大约三艘船。因此，对科林伍德来说，风险在于，当维尔纳夫沿海岸南下时，他可能会被夹在那些已经在加的斯的法国船只、加的斯的西班牙船只以及维尔纳夫的军队之间。所以他撤退了；他召回了更多的船只，在天边徘徊，不想让法国人知道他只有这么少船，但封锁仍在继续，维尔纳夫最终困在了加的斯。维尔纳夫大约有33艘船，是的，他有33艘船。拿破仑觉得这足够了，如果他从罗什福尔
and breast why shouldn't he come up the channel yeah it's more than enough i think napoleon is being over optimistic well napoleon is furious and he furious. And he condemns Villeneuve as a coward. And essentially it persuades Napoleon to give up on the entire plan. And by this point, Pitt has been maneuvering. He's got Austria and Russia back into the war. And so Napoleon decides, well, I'm not going to hang around
和布雷斯特征集更多船只的话，为什么不驶上英吉利海峡呢？是的，绰绰有余。我认为拿破仑过于乐观了。好吧，拿破仑怒不可遏，他气疯了。他谴责维尔纳夫是个懦夫。这基本上说服了拿破仑放弃了整个计划。此时，皮特一直在运筹帷幄。他把奥地利和俄罗斯重新拉回了战争。所以拿破仑决定，好吧，我不会再在这里闲逛了
gazing across the straits at the Cliffs of Dover. There's no point. I'm going to go off and fight the Battle of Austerlitz. So that's what he does. He goes herring off to fight war in Central Europe. And the threat of invasion is passed. Meanwhile, Nelson has crossed back across the Atlantic. He's landed at Gibraltar.
隔着海峡凝视多佛尔白崖。毫无意义。我要去打奥斯特利茨战役。所以他就是这么做的。他急急忙忙地去中欧打仗了。入侵的威胁已经过去。与此同时，纳尔逊已经横渡大西洋返回。他在直布罗陀登陆。
He steps on land for the first time in two years. He's been at ship for two years yeah that i mean it's extraordinary to think of what that must be like imagine the wobbling as you walk on that kind of swaying so he he decides he's going to go back to london uh get his orders and and discuss what what should be done and so he he heads back to london in london waiting for him is lady hamilton in their house. Everybody knows, everybody knows that they are lovers and they've got this incredibly
这是他两年来第一次踏上陆地。他已经在船上待了两年了，是的——我的意思是，想到那会是什么样子真是不可思议，想象一下走在那种摇晃的东西上的眩晕感——所以他决定返回伦敦，去获取命令并讨论应该做些什么。于是他动身返回伦敦。在伦敦的家中，埃米莉·汉密尔顿夫人正在等他。每个人都知道，每个人都知道他们是一对情侣，他们有着这种令人难以置信的
scandalous relationship. Yes. And he, they have a house in Merton in South, in what is now Southwest London, but at the time was a village. It's on the main road between London and Portsmouth. So very convenient for Nelson to,
丑闻般的关系。是的。而且他们在南伦敦的默顿有一所房子——在现在的西南伦敦，但当时那还是一个村庄。它位于伦敦和朴茨茅斯之间的大路上。所以纳尔逊如果被召集，去朴茨茅斯非常方便，而且去伦敦、去海军部或唐宁街等地也很方便。埃玛·汉密尔顿一直在忙着把它打造成一个适合纳尔逊的地方。她就在万德尔河畔，那是几条河流之一。纳尔逊在家的时候会在万德尔河钓鱼。他有一条护城河，不是吗？是的，他们把它叫做尼罗河。整座房子绝对是供奉纳尔逊和埃玛的神殿。我真希望我也能有一座这样的房子。
to go to Portsmouth if summoned, but also to go into London, to talk to the Admiralty or to Downing Street or whatever. Emma Hamilton has been busy making it a place fit for Nelson. So she is by the Wandel, which is one of the rivers. Nelson fishes on the Wandel when he's at home. He's got a moat, hasn't he? Yes, that they call the Nile. The whole house is an absolute shrine to Nelson and Emma. I wish I had a house like that.
是的。绝对太棒了。非常遗憾的是，它在1823年被拆毁了。但是参观那里的人会发现，通往宏伟大道的一个入口处有一个叫“纳尔逊徽章”的酒吧。哦，那挺好的。尽管当然，纳尔逊只有一只胳膊。如果他们把酒吧改名为“纳尔逊单臂”酒吧，我会给它打高分的。
Yeah. Absolutely brilliant. And very sadly, it was demolished in 1823. But people who visit it, there's an entrance to the Grand Drive that's marked by a pub called the Nelson Arms. Oh, that's nice. Even though, of course, Nelson only had one arm. I'd give the pub so much credit if they'd rename it the Nelson Arm.
是的，那会很棒，对吧？无论如何，所以纳尔逊在那里，但他频繁进出伦敦。他是当之无愧的时代英雄。所以有人说，无论纳尔逊走到哪里，空气中都回荡着欢呼声。多米尼克，难道你不想这样吗？我的意思是，我从不出门。因此，他的朋友这样描述道：“看到全世界的惊叹、钦佩、爱戴和尊敬，以及所有这些情感从温和纯朴的人们身上同时自然流露出来，这实在是非常感人的，纳尔逊被看到的那一刻，超越了任何
Yeah, that would be great, wouldn't it? Anyway, so Nelson's there, but he's going in and out of London. He's absolute hero of the hour. And so someone says, wherever Nelson goes, the air rings with huzzahs. Wouldn't you love that dominic i mean i never go out so a friend of his describes it's really quite affecting to see the wonder and admiration and love and respect of the whole world and the general expression of all these sentiments at once from the gentle and simple the moment he has seen it is beyond anything
戏剧或诗歌中所表现的声誉。”汤姆，当你走进“历史其余部分”俱乐部聚会的房间时，就会发生这种情况。是的，但我认为我，你知道的，我缺乏这种荷马式的品质。这也是那种观点，即纳尔逊已经是某首诗或某出戏里的英雄了，是的，他是在有意识地扮演那个角色。他是英格兰的雄狮。这就是全部意义所在。好吧，连高层的人也这么想，汤姆，因为民众这么想，他们喜欢看到他并为他欢呼。但是当他去伦敦时，小皮特，威廉·皮特，向纳尔逊表达了敬意，不是吗？
represented in a play or a poem of fame tom that's what happens when you walk into the room at a rest is history club get together yeah but i i think i like you know i lack this homeric quality and it's again it's that idea that it's this idea that nelson is is already the hero of a poem or a play yeah and he's consciously playing that role. He is England's lion. That's the whole point. Well, even the people at the top think that, Tom, because the crowds think it and they love to see him and they cheer him. But when he goes to London, Pitt the Younger, William Pitt, he pays homage to Nelson, doesn't he?
他陪着他走到马车旁。是的，当他最后一次离开时，所以——这反映了这样一个事实：纳尔逊一直在与皮特、海军部进行讨论，并在他在默顿的花园里散步、钓鱼、欣赏埃玛到处放置的关于他的半身像时，他正在策划他的战略应该是什么。因为他想做的是做他在尼罗河时做过的事，那就是追求一场歼灭战。但他想比在尼罗河时更积极地推进这场战斗。因为纳尔逊认识到，正如海军部所认识到的、皮特所认识到的那样，如果英国人能够摧毁法国和西班牙海军，那么英国不仅
He walks with him to his carriage. Yeah, when he goes for the last time when he's leaving so so and that reflects the fact that nelson has been in discussion with pitt with the admiralty and walking around his garden in merton uh doing his fishing and uh admiring all the busts of him that emma has put up everywhere he is plotting what his strategy should be because what he wants to do is is to do what he did at the Nile, which is to pursue a battle of annihilation. But he wants to pursue it even more aggressively than he'd done at the Nile. Because Nelson recognises, as the Admiralty do, as Pitt recognises, that if the British can destroy the French and Spanish navies, then Britain will not
能够，你知道的，让法国人无法入侵，而且英国还可以夺取法、西两国的贸易，将其接管。通过这样做，使他们陷入贫困，从而阻止他们再以英国人那样的规模发展舰队。好吧，你可以在欧洲封锁他们。你可以切断他们的进口。你可以摧毁他们的贸易。这需要时间，但你知道你会赢得这场战争。我的意思是，这需要几年的时间，但你能做到。他的计划是消灭敌人。他之所以能够做到这一点，是因为即使带上了他所出动的那数量的船只
only, you know, it'll be impossible for the French to invade, but Britain can also seize French and Spanish trade, take it over. And by doing that, impoverish them and then prevent them from ever kind of developing fleets on the scale that the British have. Well, you can blockade them in Europe. You can starve them of imports. You can destroy their trade. It will take time, but you know that you will win that war. I mean, it will take years, but you can do it. His plan is to annihilate the enemy. And he's able to do that because even taking the number of ships that he does,
那也只占英国总兵力的一小部分。所以他承担得起风险，他也承担得起英国士兵生命的损失。实际上，如果你在追求一场歼灭战，英国伤亡人数并不重要。重要的是，这场战斗要对敌人造成尽可能大的破坏。为了做到这一点，汤姆，为了给人们一个剧透预览，他想贴近敌人。他想带着他的船只冲进去，刺破——你知道的，因为我们没有谈论过海战，18th世纪的海战有一种略带仪式感的元素，不是吗？双方排成队列，实际上就是互相射击，是的。纳尔逊想做的是径直冲向敌人，在两个地方刺破他们的
that's only a fraction of the total British force. So he can afford to take a risk and he can afford to lose British lives. Actually, the number of British casualties are not going to be important if you're pursuing a battle of annihilation. What matters is that the battle causes as much destruction as possible to the enemy. And his plan for doing that, Tom, just to give people a sort of sneak preview, he wants to get right up close. He wants to take his ships and pierce you know because we haven't talked about naval battles and there's a sort of slightly ritualistic element isn't there to 18th century naval battles the two sides kind of line up and shoot at each other effectively yeah and what nelson wants to do is he wants to head straight for the enemy pierce their
战线，并且靠得非常近。正如他所说的，他说：“他们不会知道我在做什么。这将引发一场混战，而这正是我想要的。”我的意思是，他想要的是血腥杀戮、混乱、近距离格斗，将这些提升到绝对的最高点，因为他确信凭借英国占优的纪律、炮术以及诸如此类的一切，当他们近距离接触时，他认为自己无论如何都不可能输。
line in two places and and get really close. What he calls, he says, they will not know what I'm about. It will bring forward a pell-mell battle, and that is what I want. I mean, what he wants is the carnage, the chaos, the close quarters fighting to be sort of turned up to the absolute maximum because he is confident that the superior British discipline, the gunnery and all that kind of thing, that when they're up close, he thinks there's no way really he can lose.
差不多就是这样，不是吗？是的。所以我想这个计划在两个层面上运作。首先，正如我们在第一集讨论过的，英国的炮术要优越得多，在近距离上非常有效，如果他们能贴近敌人，基本上，你知道的，英国大炮直接瞄准法国或西班牙大炮，这对敌舰的影响将是绝对毁灭性的。但我也认为，这是为了制造混乱。从17世纪到18世纪进行的那些海战，旨在将某种图案强加于海战的混乱之中。这就像你在简·奥斯汀电影中看到的那些舞蹈。
That's pretty much it, isn't it? Yeah. So I think the plan is operating on two levels. The first is, as we discussed in the first episode, that British gunnery is so superior and is so effective at close quarters that if they can get right up close, so basically, you know, the British guns are aimed straight at the French or Spanish guns, the impact of that will be absolutely devastating on the enemy ships. But it's also, I think, to create chaos. The naval battles fought in the, you know, from the 17th through the 18th centuries are designed to impose a kind of patterning on the chaos of naval battles. It's like the kind of dances that you get in Jane Austen films.
人们排好队开火，然后撤退。这有点像小步舞曲。纳尔逊想要撕碎这一切，他想要制造混乱。他想在英国舰队运作极限的边缘行动，并满怀信心地认为这将摧毁西班牙和法国，因为他们将缺乏应对这种局面的专业素养。当他起草他的计划时，他有一位朋友，理查德·基茨船长，他的船长之一，来和他在默顿的花园里散步。纳尔逊把计划告诉了他，并说：“你觉得怎么样？”基茨对这个计划的
People line up and fire, and then they kind of withdraw. It's kind of minuet. Nelson wants to rip that up, and he wants to create chaos. He wants to operate at the edge of what is possible for the British fleet to operate in the full confidence that that will destroy the Spanish and French because they will lack the professionalism to cope with that. When he's drawing up his plan, he has a friend, Captain Richard Keats, one of his captains, to come and stroll in the garden with him at Merton. And Nelson tells him the plan and says, well, what do you think of it? And Keats is astounded
大胆感到震惊。他觉得，你知道的，这太惊险刺激、太雄心勃勃了。他不知道该说什么。纳尔逊自问自答道：“我来告诉你我的看法。我认为这会让敌人大吃一惊，晕头转向。他们不会知道我在搞什么鬼。”这正是你的观点。出其不意、混乱、打破常规，所有这些东西。在某种程度上，这是一种源于他对其余法、西两国蔑视的战略。他假设自己能够彻底击溃他们。这是一种桑布里克式的战略。一种桑布里克式的战略。
by the audacity of the plan. He thinks, you know, it's so swashbuckling, so ambitious. And he doesn't know what to say. And Nelson answers his own question and says, I'll tell you what I think of it. I think it will surprise and confound the enemy. They will not know what I'm about. And that's exactly your point. It's the surprise, the chaos, the breaking with convention, all of that kind of stuff. In a way, it's a strategy bred of his contempt for the French and Spanish. He is assuming that he can break them utterly. A Sandbrookian strategy. A Sandbrookian strategy.
这就是计划。所以他与伦敦的高层指挥官们讨论了此事。正如你所说，他与皮特进行了最后一次会面，皮特为了表示敬意，一直陪他走到马车旁。他去了殖民部，在那里他遇到了独一无二的阿瑟·韦尔斯利爵士，未来的威灵顿公爵。哇。我的意思是，这并不是一次伟大的——我的意思是，这比普鲁斯特和乔伊斯的会面还要好，或者诸如此类。确实如此。
So that is the plan. And so he talks it over with the high command in London. And as you say, he has his last meeting with Pitt, who walks him to the carriage as a mark of his respect. He goes to the colonial office where he meets the one and only time Sir Arthur Wellesley, the future Duke of Wellington. Wow. I mean, but it's not a great, I mean, it's better than the meeting of Proust and Joyce or whatever. It is.
确实如此。好吧，因为韦尔斯利，未来的威灵顿对纳尔逊心存疑虑。当他们初次交谈时，他觉得纳尔逊有点自以为是。但到最后，他被说服了，并表示：“我觉得我从未有过比这更令我感兴趣的谈话。”纳尔逊还被传召去晋见摄政王。这可能更谈不上心有灵犀了。是的。那是9月12日。9月13日，纳尔逊在默顿与埃玛度过了一天。晚上10点30分，他坐上前往朴茨茅斯的四轮马车。所以他坐着马车从默顿沿着朴茨茅斯公路疾驰而下，抵达了那里。第二天早上，他划船登上“胜利”号。有两个人——那个时代非常杰出的政治家乔治·卡宁，许多酒吧都以他的名字命名，就是其中之一——陪同他登上他的旗舰。然后在9月15日，“胜利”号离开朴茨茅斯扬帆起航，一路南下，带着舰队抵达了加的斯外海。他加入了科林伍德的部队，此时该部队已经扩充到
It is. Well, because Wellesley, the the Future Wellington is suspicious of Nelson. And when they first talk, thinks he's a bit full of himself. But by the end is one round and says that I don't feel that I ever had a conversation that interested me more. And Nelson is also summoned to see the Prince Regent. Probably less of a meeting of minds. Yeah. So that's on the 12th of September. 13th of September, Nelson spends the day at Merton with Emma. 10.30 in the evening, he takes a chaise for Portsmouth. So he rattles down from Merton down the Portsmouth Road, arrives there. The next morning, he rows out to Victory. And two men, so George Canning, very eminent politician of the age, given his name to many pubs, is one of them, accompanies him to his flagship. And then on the 15th of September, Victory leaves Portsmouth, sails off, and sails down and arrives with his fleet off Cadiz. He is joining Collingwood's force which by this point has had swollen to
八艘船，呃，他加入了考尔德的部队。考尔德就是那个与维尔纳夫进行了一场没有分出胜负的战斗、并让维尔纳夫感到惊慌害怕的人，考尔德已被召回接受军事法庭的审判。纳尔逊对此表现得非常骑士风度。他告诉考尔德：“别走。我想你应该留在这里战斗。”当考尔德觉得于荣誉有亏必须离开时，他允许考尔德乘坐自己的旗舰离开。因此纳尔逊的兵力为此减少了一艘船。纳尔逊做的另一件事是打发走更多的船只——我想是四艘或五艘——去往
eight ships um and he joins calder's force so calder is the guy who had fought the um indecisive battle against villeneuve that had had alarmed and frightened villeneuve and calder has been summoned back to answer a court-martial. And Nelson is very chivalrous about this. He tells Calder, don't go. I think you should stay here and fight. And when Calder feels honour bound to go, he allows Calder to go in his flagship. So Nelson's force is depleted by one ship as a result of that. And something else that Nelson does is to send away a further number of ships i think it's four or five um to go to
直布罗陀，表面上是为了加强直布罗陀的城防，但几乎可以肯定，其目的是让维尔纳夫的间谍能够看到纳尔逊正在削减他的兵力。你知道，呃——好吧，你知道，因为你有我的笔记。我就假装我不知道吧。那五艘被派往直布罗陀、最终没有参加特拉法加战役的船只上的一名军官，难道是查尔斯·狄更斯的父亲吗，汤姆？不，是简·奥斯汀的兄弟弗朗西斯。哇，真是个大开眼界的内幕，谁知道他曾是科林伍德加的斯分舰队的一员呢，而且他对被纳尔逊打发走感到非常非常沮丧。所以他最终没有参加这场冲突。有一个美妙的时刻，不是吗？纳尔逊在我想是10月1日写信给埃玛。他说他开过这样一个会议，把所有的船长都叫到了他的船舱里。他把计划告诉了他们，这个令人难以置信的激进计划。他说，当我向他们解释
gibraltar ostensibly to to to strengthen the garrison in gibraltar but almost certainly the aim of that is that um villeneuve spies should be able to see that nelson is depleting his forces and do you know the uh well you do because you've got my notes the i'll pretend i don't one at one of the officers on those five ships that gets sent off to gibraltar so ends up not fighting at the battle of trafalgar is it the the father of charles dickens tom no it's it's the brother of jane austen francis wow what a revelation who knew who knew that he'd been part of collingwood squadron of cadiz and um very very upset to be sent off by Nelson. So he ends up not taking part in the conflict. There's a lovely moment, isn't there? Nelson writes to Emma on, I think, the 1st of October. And he says he's had this meeting where he's got all the captains in his cabin. And he tells them the plan, this incredibly aggressive plan he says when i came to explain to them the
直布罗陀，表面上是为了加强直布罗陀的守军，但几乎可以肯定，这么做的目的是让维尔讷夫的间谍能看到纳尔逊正在削弱自己的兵力，你知道那个——好吧，你知道，因为你有我的笔记。我就假装不知道好了。被派往直布罗陀的那五艘船上的一位军官，最终没有参加特拉法尔加海战，他是查尔斯·狄更斯的父亲吗？汤姆，不，是简·奥斯汀的兄弟弗朗西斯。哇，真是个惊天大密辛！谁能想到他曾是科林伍德在加的斯的舰队的一员呢？而且他非常、非常懊恼被纳尔逊派走，所以他最终没有参加这场冲突。有一个非常动人的时刻，对吧？纳尔逊在10月1日写信给艾玛，我想是这样的。他说他开过一个会，把所有船长都叫到了他的船舱里，他向他们讲述了那个计划，那个极其激进的计划，他说当他开始向他们解释
nelson touch it was like an electric shock some shed tears all approved it was new it was singular it was simple and from the admirals downwards it was repeated it must succeed if ever they will allow us to get at them you are my lord surrounded by friends whom you inspire with confidence yeah and nelson tells them it is annihilation that the country wants splendid stuff the stage is almost set tom yeah he's very very excited about this this plan but obviously it requires the french and spanish to leave cadiz you know the french and spanish have been very very reluctant to face the Royal Navy. So the question is, why does Villeneuve leave? Well, first of all, he's given direct orders by Napoleon to take troops from Cadiz to Southern Italy and Sicily. So those are direct orders. Furthermore, his pal, Denis de Cray, the Minister for the Navy back in Paris, sends him a coded warning that Napoleon
要撤掉他的职并把他召回巴黎，基本上是说，“你知道的，你应该出去同英国人作战并打败他们，如果你不想惹上大麻烦的话。”而且加的斯没有多少物资，你知道的，那里黄热病肆虐，对于驻扎一支庞大舰队来说，这实在不是个好地方。所以出于所有这些原因，我认为促使维尔纳夫觉得他真的没有什么可失去的，他必须这么做。维尔纳夫在舰船数量上占有优势。他有33艘船，而英国人有27艘。他在人数上也多得多。他有3万名官兵和男孩。英国人有1.7万名官兵和男孩。所以他也许会想，我不仅没有什么可失去的，而且我很有可能赢得这场战斗，或者至少相对毫发无损地脱身。
is going to sack him and summon him back to Paris and basically says, you know, you should get out there and you should fight the British and defeat them if you don't want to get into serious trouble. And also Cadiz doesn't have many supplies and it's, you know, there is a yellow fever raging and it's really not a good place for a large fleet to be stationed. So all those reasons, I think, prompt Villeneuve to feel that he has nothing to lose, really, that he has to do it. Villeneuve has the advantage of numbers of ships. He has 33 ships and the British have 27. He also has far more men. He has 30,000 men and boys. The British have 17,000 men and boys. So he perhaps thinks, not only do I have nothing to lose, but there's a really good chance I could win this, or at least escape relatively
“纳尔逊式触击”时，那就像是一场电击。有些人流下了眼泪，所有人都表示赞同。它是崭新的、独特的、简明的，从海军将领到普通官兵，大家都在重复着：只要他们敢让我们接近，就一定会成功！大人，您被朋友们环绕着，您给予了他们信心。是的，纳尔逊告诉他们，祖国需要的是彻底歼灭。太棒了。大幕即将拉开，汤姆。是的，他对这个计划感到非常非常兴奋。但显然这需要法西联军离开加的斯，你知道，法西联军一直非常非常不愿意与皇家海军正面交锋。所以问题是，维尔纳夫为什么要离开？好吧，首先，他接到了拿破仑的直接命令，要求将军队从加的斯运往意大利南部和西西里岛。所以那是直接命令。此外，他在巴黎的死党、海军大臣德尼·克雷给他发了一条加密警告，说拿破仑
unscathed. I think escaping relatively unscathed is the best that he's hoping for. He also, of course, has to persuade the Spanish. And the Spanish are led by a guy called Federico Gravina, who is, in fact, from Sicily. So a bit like Napoleon, he speaks Italian as his first language. He's a very distinguished line of Spanish aristocrats. And one of the reasons I think why Nelson sends ships away from his own fleet, so to diminish it, is that it makes it impossible for Gravina and the Spanish to stay in harbour. They can't stay there without dishonouring themselves. The British fleet is palpably smaller than the combined fleet of the French and Spanish. They essentially are honour bound to go out as well. So all of which results in, on the 18th of October, the French and Spanish
毫发无伤。我认为相对毫发无伤是他能期待的最好的结果了。当然，他还需要说服西班牙人。西班牙人由一个叫费德里科·格拉维纳的人领导，他实际上来自西瓜里——呃，西西里。所以就像拿破仑一样，他的母语是意大利语。他出身于一个非常显赫的西班牙贵族世家。我认为纳尔逊把船只从自己的舰队中调离、从而削弱兵力的原因之一，就是让格拉维纳和西班牙人不可能继续呆在港口里。他们不迎战就等于自取耻辱，无法继续呆下去了。英国舰队明显比法西联合舰队要小。从荣誉上讲，他们也必须出战。所有这些导致的结果是，在10月18日，法国和西班牙
go to mass in Cadiz. They embarking 19th of october they they sail out uh into the the bay of cadiz yeah they're out in the bay of cadiz the wind drops they're absolutely stationary they're kind of stuck there nightmare 20th of october very light breeze starts to pick up again combined fleetined fleet gets underway, heading southwards down towards Cape Trafalgar, towards the Straits of Gibraltar. And then it starts to rain. The winds pick up. Incredible gloom, very low visibility.
在加的斯做弥撒。他们在10月19日登船，驶向加的斯湾。是的，他们到了加的斯湾，风停了，完全静止了，他们有点被困在那里了，简直是一场噩梦。10月20日，微风再次开始刮起，联合舰队起航，向南朝着特拉法尔加角、直布罗陀海峡方向驶去。接着开始下雨了，风力增强，一片阴暗，能见度极低。
And the British ships, much further out in the Atlantic, lots of the captains are worried that the the French and Spanish have retreated back into Cadiz and that they've lost their opportunity to to have a to win the battle but by night time it's evident that actually the French and Spanish are still out at sea and that means that on the evening of the 20th of October, 1805, everyone knows, the British fleet, as on the French and Spanish fleet, that in the morning there will be a battle. And that very day, Tom, Nelson has sat and has been sitting in his cabin and he's written two letters, hasn't he?
而英国船只在更远的大西洋上，许多船长担心法西联军已经退回加的斯，他们失去了赢得这场战役的机会。但到了夜里，很明显法国和西班牙人仍然在海上，这意味着在1805年10月20日的傍晚，每个人——英国舰队以及法国和西班牙舰队——都知道，明天早上将有一场大战。就在那天，汤姆，纳尔逊一直坐在他的船舱里，写了两封信，对吧？
One to his daughter, horatia his daughter lady hamilton i rejoice that you're so very good a girl and i and you love my dear lady hamilton who most dearly loves you i will be sure of your prayers for my safety blah blah blah be a good girl and he's also written a letter to lady to emma hamilton um may the god of battles crown my endeavors with success etc et cetera, et cetera. But he doesn't finish the letter because he wants to finish it after the battle. So, Tom, the stage now is well and truly set, isn't it? And as it happens, this is going out on the day before Trafalgar, isn't it?
一封写给他的女儿霍拉西亚，他女儿哈密尔顿夫人——“我很高兴你是个如此乖巧的女孩，你也爱我亲爱的哈密尔顿夫人，她最深爱着你，我确信你会为我的安全祈祷，等等等等，要做个乖女孩”。他还写了一封信给汉密尔顿夫人艾玛，“愿战神使我的努力取得成功，等等，等等，等等”。但他没有写完这封信，因为他想在战役结束后再写完它。所以，汤姆，现在舞台真的已经搭好了，对吧？碰巧的是，这期节目正是在特拉法尔加日的前一天播出，对吧？
So tomorrow, the 21st of October, is Trafalgar Day. And the good news for our listeners is that we are very much a podcast in true late 18th, early 19th century spirit. We are both patriotic and commercial, aren't we, Tom? So the good news is that if you too are patriotic and commercial, you can listen to our account of the Battle of Trafalgar on Trafalgar Day if you're a member of the rest is history club which is to podcasting what the royal navy was to 18th century warfare it's it's disciplined it's streamlined and it has an awful lot of limes so so you can join if you're a member of the rest is history club tomorrow on Trafalgar Day you can dance a jig
所以明天，10月21日，就是特拉法尔加日。对于我们的听众来说好消息是，我们非常具有18世纪晚期、19世纪早期精神的播客风格。我们既爱国又具有商业头脑，对吧，汤姆？所以好消息是，如果你也很爱国且具有商业头脑，你可以成为“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，在特拉法尔加日收听我们对特拉法尔加海战的解说。这个俱乐部之于播客，就像皇家海军之于18世纪的战争——纪律严明、精简高效，而且有大量的青柠。所以你可以加入，如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，明天在特拉法尔加日，你可以跳一支吉格舞
you can sing Heart of Oak you can do all that stuff Splice the main brace all that kind of stuff exactly you can interfere with Marlin Spikes
你可以唱《橡木之心》，你可以做所有那些事，拼接主支索，所有那些类型的干草，完全可以，你可以去拨弄马林钉
and jibs and stuff and you can listen to our account of the Battle of Trafalgar if you're not a member of the rest is history club just head to Apple Spotify
和三角帆之类的事，你可以收听我们对特拉法尔加海战的解说。如果你不是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，只需前往苹果、声田
or wherever you get your podcasts on Monday next week to hear our account of the Battle of Trafalgar the final installment in this three-part saga and on that bombshell tom we will see them next time for the battle of trafalgar goodbye bye-bye
或任何你获取播客的地方，在下周一收听我们对特拉法尔加海战的解说，这是这个三部曲传奇的最后一期。带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，我们下次再见，聊聊特拉法尔加海战，再见，拜拜
thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家附加节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》，这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻评论
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
一抹八卦花絮，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
附加节目以及优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。